hacker-angriffe rückgrat des
wissenschaftsjournalismus gehackt ja bei
fachmagazin oder wissenschafts portalen
ist die glaubwürdigkeit einer absolut
wichtige sache betrug oder die
übermittlung von falschen informationen
das sollte es nicht geben und dafür gibt
es ein portal und genau das ist jetzt
gehackt worden alle infos jetzt bei
klick zum tanzen fiction ja letzte woche
musste eines der angesehensten
wissenschafts portale schlechthin
aufgrund eines hacker angriffs aus dem
netz genommen werden jurek allard wenn
der name nicht sagt er eine kurze
erklärung das portal hat mehr als 12.000
mitglieder die aus rund 90 verschiedenen
ländern kommen und stellt sozusagen die
zentrale schnittstelle zwischen
fachmagazin wie zum beispiel science
vielen universitäten und dem weltweiten
wissenschaftsjournalismus da jörg ernert
symbolisiert also salopp gesagt das
rückgrat der öffentlichkeitsarbeit der
wissenschaft und erleichtert
journalisten maßgeblich die aber zitat
ein journalist kann nicht jede woche 50
bis 100 seiten vom fachjournal und
universitäten abklappern
daher kam die idee eine einzige
plattform für den geschützten austausch
von informationen zu schaffen so nennen
broadband von der american association
for the advancement of science aaas
geschützt scheint gerade aber gar nichts
mehr zusammen mit den worten hallo herr
hummel ich weiß dass sie von new york
wegen einer sperrfrist verletzung bis
oktober ausgeschlossen sind wenn sie
interesse haben kann ich ihnen einen
kaum besorgen mit dem sie wieder auf
informationen unter sperrfrist zugreifen
können das system von jurek alles ist
sehr schlecht geschützt es war nicht
schwer die nötigen informationen
zusammen ich habe tausende zugangsdaten
beschaffen können meldete sich ein
dubioser twitter-user am 11 september
bei dem welttournee listen philipp
hummel hummel hatte wie der hacker
richtig schreibt aus versehen ein
embargo verletzt und wurde daher für 90
tage aus dem eurocup netz ausgeschlossen
hummel zeigte sich dem haka gegenüber
wie er selbst in seinem so legte ich die
wichtigste wissenschaft seite der welt
lahm artikel schreibt interessiert und
leitete parallel dazu aber sämtliche
informationen am brian lynch den
redaktionsleiter für strategische
inhalts planung bei eurogate weiter j
allard wurde daraufhin direkt vom netz
genommen
das mitunter wicht
höchste wissenschaftliche
informationsportal war von einem auf den
anderen tag nicht mehr zu erreichen
steht statt
die sperrfristen und einem bus besagen
auf der seite übrigens das artikel zu
bestimmten themen erst zu einem gewissen
datum veröffentlicht werden dürfen damit
diese schon vorher also die artikel
darüber geschrieben werden können gibt
es eben vorab informationen die aber
nicht veröffentlicht werden dürfen
tausende institutionen universitäten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sowie fachmagazine wurden ihre haupt
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten braucht
jetzt heißt es abwarten die betreiber
der seite arbeiten mit hochdruck an dem
ausbau von sicherheitsmaßnahmen dem
auffinden von lücken und an der
wiederbetrieb name des portals weshalb
ein solches portal ziel eines hackers
wurde lässt sich vorerst nur mutmaßen
wollte er oder sie damit den anfang
einer revolte zu den embargos über
wissen darstellen wenn ja stellt sich
die frage ob diese aktion sinnvoll war
nun steckt die wissenschaft in diesem
bereich erst mal fest neue erkenntnisse
kommen nicht mehr so schnell zum
vorschein und wahrscheinlich auch nicht
das problem mit den sperrfristen viele
betroffene nehmen das zum teil mit humor
und dennoch absurd zur kenntnis zitat an
den hacker von eurogate könntest du
deine energie bitte lieber darauf
konzentrieren die steuerunterlagen von
donald trump zu hacken
wir müssen hier wissenschaft machen
twitterte paul gabriel von der
university of utah wo wir beim thema
unter verschluss halten beziehungsweise
sicherheit sind das hörbuch global
hacker die banken ausspähten cyber
terroristen die atomkraftwerke kapern
geheimdienste die unsere handys knacken
ist für euch über unseren hörbuch link
kostenlos sagen denkt einfach auf
unseren link hier oben unter me und
natürlich auch in der video beschreibung
erstellt euch einen kostenlosen probe
account bei audible und bekommt das
hörbuch geschenkt wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann lass gerne einen
daumen nach oben und ein kostenloses abo
da dafür einfach hier klicken
und wenn er hier klickt also da dann
kommt er ein zu einem video über einen
hacker des chaos computer clubs ja viel
spaß dabei und was haltet ihr von dem
ganzen thema findet ihr es okay das
wissenschafts errungenschaft mit dem bus
also den sogenannten sperrfristen
versehen werden oder sollte man
sämtliche erkenntnisse direkt und
unverzüglich der öffentlichkeit
zugänglich macht
in den kommentaren wissen bis dann
bleibt dran